okay due to a combination of stupidity
and lack of technical knowledge I guess
I would say Paul Manafort own lawyers
have completely blown the door open on
Russian collusion and we now have for
the first time thanks to Trump's meta
forts lawyers we have a trump campaign
official confirming their intent to
collude with Russia on the 2016 election
and they actually did so this story is
so incredible in the ignorance and
stupidity that it exposes that it almost
stretches credulity that this has even
happened but it happened and I'm going
to explain it to you today you'll
remember that Donald Trump's former
campaign manager Paul Manafort has been
convicted of all sorts of crimes this
happened last year now his lawyers are
saying that he is really not doing well
physically or psychologically in prison
and that is now being brought to a
court's attention but what you may
remember is that he has done a lot of
bad things not only that he commits a
bunch of crimes for which he was
convicted
he got himself into more trouble because
after making a cooperation agreement
with Robert Mulder's prosecutors he lied
even more which is a violation of the
plea agreement
his lawyers responded to that claim as
lawyers do but they messed up big time
because what man affords lawyers tried
to do was to put out a filing that
redacted four sections in their filing
and blacked them out and we're actually
putting up just one page of this filing
and people can see on screen right now
that the court filing has a bunch of
different lines that are blacked out
redacted so to speak except they didn't
do it correctly and even though in the
image we have up on the screen a bunch
of text is blacked out it looks redacted
this was done in such a way that if you
merely highlighted that blacked out text
copied it and then pasted it into
another document on your computer in
Microsoft Word or in WordPad or notepad
it pasted the full unredacted text of
what was covered up meant to be covered
up an incredible mistake and the real
blockbuster
isn't the ignorant lawyers a technically
ignorant lawyers of Paul Manafort it's
the content of what they tried to redact
because the redacted text says that mana
fort lied to Muller about meeting
Constantine Killam Nick during the 2016
campaign specifically to talk about the
quote Ukraine peace plan which is code
for the Trump administration's softening
on US policy towards Russia for their
actions in Ukraine Killam Nick is
connected to Russian intelligence so
this is a document not from Christopher
Steele not from Democratic operatives
this is a document from mana Ford's own
attorneys which confirms that the
campaign chairman of the Republican
nominee for president who eventually
became the president met with a Russian
intelligence agent I'm sorry
met with an individual connected to
Russian intelligence during the campaign
specifically to discuss what would
Republican policy be towards Russia and
Ukraine and to share polling data with
that same Russian individual the
document confirms collusion now remember
collusion in and of itself is not a
crime if Donald Trump knew that this was
going on that would be conspiracy and it
would potentially be obstruction of
justice depending on how Donald Trump
answered those questions in writing to
Robert Muller and there's a whole bunch
of possible crimes that are connected to
what is admitted here in this faulty
redaction of a Paul Manafort document
remember how Russian actors ran those
targeted campaigns to try to influence
the election and one of the things they
did was target voters in specific parts
of the United States in certain ways and
in other parts of the United States in
other ways Killam Nick is a business
associate of Russian oligarch Oleg
Deripaska who has been tied into
influence campaigns and by the way the
Trump administration decided to lift
sanctions on Deripaska he's connected to
the guy manna fort was meeting with so
this has been blown wide open pat
by mana Ford's own lawyers yeah these
people are criminals but they're not
criminal masterminds and contrary to
popular belief they do not have the best
people working for them if you want to
get away with a crime as serious as
colluding with a foreign power to win an
election you have to be smart about it
you have to outsmart the FBI and make
sure that you cover your tracks it
doesn't really look like they did that
in this case yes and of course collusion
again not in and of itself a crime but
the entire conspiracy to do this and the
cover-up is what may contain a whole
bunch of different criminality and this
certainly makes that case far far
stronger Trump's campaign manager while
campaign manager Paul Manafort provided
to the Russians during the campaign
remember data that they then used to
target voters in specific States to help
Donald Trump defeat Hillary Clinton the
only remaining link that we would be
looking for now is that Trump knew this
was going on that would involve him in a
criminal conspiracy with Russia to seize
the presidency this didn't get the
attention it deserves because of
surprise surprise
Trump's bogus border wall immigration
crisis prime time address last night
maybe by design maybe not who really
knows but every single box is being
checked slowly but surely
take any any one of these issues take
any of the allegations that have
surfaced over time and what at first is
a question mark
slowly but surely becomes a definitive
piece of knowledge about what it is that
took place every single box being
checked
imagine what we will know in six months
or by the end of 2019 absolutely
stunning and unfortunately again because
of the timing of Trump's border wall
address last night this should have
gotten a lot more attention and there's
some complexity in it you have to
understand not only what was the court
filing but why is it relevant that man
afford admitted to having lied to Muller
about his meetings with Killam Nick and
how kill him Nick is related but you
need to understand a bunch of stuff it's
much more interesting to corporate media
to say Trump addressing the the country
about the border wall crisis way easier
probably better ratings for them as well
follow this story and other stories from
today's show on the David Pakman show
Instagram page at David Pakman show and
while you're there follow me as well i'm
on instagram at david pakman today's
sponsor is Skillshare and i'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than 10 bucks a month
get better at whatever it is that you're
passionate about or discover something
brand new that you didn't even know that
you would love and join skill shares
other 7 million users by clicking the
link underneath this video
[Music]